hi it's michelle from lab muffin beauty
science chemistry phd skincare nerd
and asian i don't know why that's my
intro but
i've committed if you're into skincare
you'll know that there's lots of hype
around asian skincare particularly
korean and japanese products
and it's not hard to see why korean and
japanese skincare have lots of product
types that you don't really see with
western brands
and they tend to be really affordable
but there are so many products that it
can get a bit overwhelming
and because a lot of the time you need
to get these products shipped from
overseas
and it can be hard to track them down
and it's hard to get them all from the
one site
a lot of sites only stock particular
brands and so sometimes you need to buy
products from multiple sites
and then the shipping can all add up so
i was really excited when stylvana asked
me to partner with them on a sponsored
video
they have a ridiculously large range of
asian beauty brands they're like a
one-stop shop
and they have a pretty low total for
free shipping they let me pick whatever
products i wanted from their range to
review and they also gave me a discount
code this gives you 15
off selected brands and 10 off
everything else so i picked out a bunch
of really hyped up products that i've
always wanted to try
and i'm going to review them today if
you like talking nerdy about the science
behind beauty products
click the like the subscribe and the
notification bell so you don't miss any
videos
i'm going to start with the roto milano
cc this
is probably the vitamin c product that i
have read the most about that got me the
most
excited it is a japanese product and in
japan this is actually regulated as a
quasi drug
it came with a long instruction sheet
which is all in japanese so
thank you google translate for helping
me out a lot on this video
this is an ascorbic acid product now
ascorbic acid is the version of vitamin
c that has the most evidence behind it
but it's also a pain it goes off really
easily it oxidizes it goes brown
and it's one of the reasons why you hear
that vitamin c serums a lot of the time
you can only use them for about three
months before you have to chuck them out
ascorbic acid can also be quite
irritating because it is acidic
and so a lot of the time it's just not
really worth the bother for people
one of the ways that this gets around
this oxidation issue
is the packaging it's really innovative
i haven't actually seen this type of
packaging before
it has this sort of metered packaging
and
you can see if i squeeze it no matter
how hard you squeeze it it only comes
out one drop at a time
and so that means it's really hard for
air to go back into the product
and so yeah that's how it keeps the
vitamin c stable for so long
and i've had this for a while now i
think i've had this for maybe two months
and it is still completely clear there
is zero brown going on
a lot of other people have also said
that they've had this for a while and
they haven't seen it go brown they've
seen the bits around the thread go brown
but not the actual product coming out
it's also meant to be a spot treatment
which is why it comes out so slowly but
it does spread really easily so it's not
that hard to get enough out that you can
get it all over your face
there are other ingredients inside it
apart from the ascorbic acid there's
vitamin e
also potassium glycerizate which is
listed as an anti-acne ingredient
it's one of the active ingredients in
licorice extract and it's
anti-inflammatory there's also an
ingredient i haven't come across
before which is isopropyl methylphenol
it is meant to be antibacterial
so this seems to target two of the
factors that can help with acne so
inflammation and bacteria according to
the packaging there's also
a delivery system with this which helps
these active ingredients penetrate your
skin a bit deeper
this has a slippery oil-like texture it
sinks in pretty quickly it leaves a very
very slightly tacky finish
i found this to be one of the least
irritating ascorbic acid products i've
ever tried and it has
just the mildest of scents i've been
using this for my post-inflammatory
hyperpigmentation which i've been
getting from masks and also from trying
out a lot of sunscreens and it's been
working really well
now speaking of sunscreens sunscreens
are probably some of the most popular
asian skincare products
and that's because i think they have
such a light texture wearing sunscreen
daily has been coming in
asia for ages it's been decades and so
there are lots of lightweight asian
sunscreens that you're meant to wear
under makeup
so it's important to note that a lot of
asian sunscreens aren't
intended for like hardcore wear unless
they're specifically water resistant
they're not really designed to
protect you while you're going out and
being sweaty and moving around a lot so
if you're gardening if you're exercising
if you're going on a bike ride or going
to the beach
these are probably not going to be that
suitable they're really like commuter
sunscreens you're only meant to wear
them to and from the office and maybe
when you're heading off to go buy lunch
but there are some water resistant asian
sunscreens which have really nice
textures and these can stand up to
a bit more activity water resistant
means that they've been tested in water
so they've been applied to people the
people had to sit in water and then
after they got out after a certain
amount of time
they tested how much protection was left
but they do still say
to reapply if you sweat a lot if you get
into the water if you rub it off with a
towel
and that's because no sunscreen is like
a barrier that you never have to reapply
they do still break down and that's why
the legislation got rid of the word
waterproof because they're not really
waterproof they just hold up better
so today i'm going to be talking about
three water-resistant asian sunscreens
that i've tried and i actually really
liked
the first one is biore uv's watery
essence
i reviewed this back in 2014 on my blog
but they kept on reformulating it so it
seems like they do it every two years so
like 2015 2017 2019
and so theoretically they should be
reformulating it this year as well it's
kind of annoying because it means you
can't really rely on all reviews and you
always have to be really careful about
checking what year they're from
it can also be hard to work out which
version you're buying especially because
there is that language barrier
but i also really respect that they care
enough to keep on reformulating a
product to be better
and better even though the old product
was doing so well like in the old
versions this
is spf 50 plus and pa with four pluses
which is the highest protection level
you can get in japan
this uses a whole bunch of the newer
filters and interestingly they don't
have titanium dioxide
in a lot of asian sunscreen there is
titanium dioxide and unfortunately this
can give a white cast
what's new in the 2019 version is that
they have the micro defense formula
which they say is a world first
and what's really interesting to me is
that in their press release they
actually say that the reason they
started looking into this innovation was
because they weren't happy with their
old formula
according to them their all water-based
formulas didn't actually perform that
well
so their all water-based formulas didn't
always apply evenly so when you zoomed
in there were all these microscopic
cracks
plus they weren't sweat and shaving
resistant so some of the sunscreen
ingredients would come off quite easily
so this uses tiny capsules which are
smaller than micron size
and these capsules contain an
oil-soluble sunscreen ingredient
and they deliver it so that it applies
really evenly
so this gives higher coverage while
still keeping that lightweight texture
this has 80 minutes water resistance and
along with the other two sunscreens
which i'm going to talk about in a sec
it has one of the nicest textures i've
ever tried in a water-resistant
sunscreen
this does have lots of alcohol in it it
wasn't a problem for me it didn't feel
like it dried out my skin at all and i
think that's because it's also got lots
of hydrating ingredients in it i found
that this didn't sting my eyes as long
as i didn't actually rub it straight
into my open
eye this has a light floral scent and i
found that when i rubbed it on my skin
it peeled
a little bit which is pretty standard
for water resistant sunscreens but
with this one it wasn't very much at all
the next sunscreen
is the skin aqua uv super moisture gel
this is from roto which is the same
brand
as the milano cc this feels very similar
to the biore sunscreen but
i had zero peeling with it it has a
really fantastically light texture
it's water resistant and it is also
fragrance free
i love that it comes in a large pack
size which is larger than
pretty much every asian sunscreen i've
tried it's larger than a lot of
facial sunscreens from western brands as
well and it has a pump bottle which is
super super handy
now the downside is that i found that
this done my eyes quite a lot
if i put it on my eyes so the first time
i tried it
around my eyes i was actually about to
go driving and i was driving
while like crying out of one eye so
don't do that
other people have said that this doesn't
sting their eyes so it might work for
you but yeah
don't try it out right before driving
now this does also have a ton of
alcohol but it doesn't feel drying so i
think that's because they've also put
lots of glycerin hyaluronic acid
hydrolyzed collagen in it
but the alcohol will kind of whack you
in the nose
now onto my favorite sunscreen of the
three this is the anessa perfect uv
sunscreen skincare milk
last year i tried their mild milk which
my friend larry gave to me in singapore
right before 2020 really set in
unfortunately my skin
hated the mild milk i found that when i
put it on it seemed to
shift around endlessly without really
setting in
and so my makeup sort of bunched up all
over the place and it just looked really
gross and greasy
i think it's partly because i have oily
skin and partly because i live in sydney
which is quite humid
and so that sort of silly coney product
just doesn't really set
now i've talked to some people with dry
skin and they
love that sort of texture so if you have
dry skin then the mild milk might work
for you
that one also clogged the crap out of my
pores
but this one this is the 20 20 version
of the skincare milk
it is in a slightly darker gold bottle
and it has a blue top
so be really careful if you're buying a
nessa sunscreen double check the name
and double check the packaging so you
don't buy the wrong one
this is a combination sunscreen that
seems to contain like
every sunscreen filter this is 80
minutes water resistant it's also rub
resistant sweat resistant heat resistant
apparently it spreads even better
if you have heat this is also apparently
mask stuffiness resistant which is like
the most
20 20 claim i have no idea how they
tested that i found that this doesn't
peel
it gives me no eye irritation and it
works super well under makeup it's a
fantastic makeup primer
now this is my favorite of the three but
it is also the most expensive of the
three
now last time i checked the skin aqua
was the cheapest of the three per ml
but the biore comes in a smaller pack
size so this ends up being cheaper to
buy if you just want to buy one product
i also tried the sun by me aha bha pha
30 days miracle acne clear body cleanser
i chose this product because i was
excited to see
a body acne product because i destroyed
my hair
for fashion i have to use really heavy
hair conditioners
and a lot of the time they stay on my
back and they clog my pores and so i get
a lot of back acne
the best way to deal with that is to
wash my back really thoroughly in the
shower
but that can be really difficult because
i'm also kind of buff
and so it can be hard to reach back
there i just found that this cleansing
is so easy to use
it's obviously in a huge bottle it has a
pump chop which is always convenient
it foams up really well and it rinses
away really well
in terms of ingredients it's got 10 000
parts per million tea tree oil which
translates to about one percent
there's also aha 0.5 percent salicylic
acid and pha
i don't know if it's the active
ingredients or just the fact that it's a
really effective cleanser
or probably a combination of both but
i've been using this for about six weeks
and i've seen
a lot less back acne it's not stripping
on my skin i don't feel any tightness
afterwards and it hasn't been irritating
but it is also
summer in sydney so i'm looking forward
to trying this out in winter and seeing
if that's still the case
so interestingly after i tried it i
looked at the ingredients and there were
some soap like ingredients in it so i
tested the ph and it turns out the ph is
actually quite high
so it's 9 to 10. usually i avoid soap
surfactants and high ph cleansers but
i think in this case it was actually
really effective
i think maybe the high ph actually
helped wash away conditioner
because hair conditioner is acidic a lot
of the time if you have an acidic thing
it's easy to wash it away with a basic
thing so maybe i was playing myself all
along by using only low ph
cleanses on my back maybe my back did
actually need a high ph cleanser
and that high ph was counteracted with
how effective it is so i don't know this
works really well for me
i also picked up a little trio of remind
lip products
i got a whole bunch of recommendations
for this brand after i complained about
how hard it was to find
brick coloured lipsticks in western
stores this collection is called the
best tint edition and it is the warm
tone version
there are two types of products in the
pack the first type is
the zero velvet tint which is like a
matte lipstick
and then after the matte lipstick wears
off then you're left with a really
pretty tint
the other products are the juicy lasting
tints and these are sort of like
a pretty pigmented lip gloss and again
they leave behind a really nice tint
these give you a much more natural look
this is more of
a solid lipstick look unlike a lot of
lip tints i've tried in the past these
are really moisturizing and they don't
really cling to dry patches as badly
this is really important for me because
i have pretty fat lips
and so i find that they tend to dry out
really easily and i always have dry
patches so
not highlighting these dry patches is
pretty important
i've been really enjoying wearing these
under a mask because they tend to last a
bit longer than lip products so
if i know i'm going to be wearing a mask
for a long time and i want to look good
after i take it off
i put on one of these and then i let it
sort of stain a bit
and then i blot it off a bit put on a
clear lip gloss or a lip balm and then
put the mask on
and so that gives me i guess a bit of a
shield over the long lasting color these
also look really good on their own and
at the moment i'm actually wearing this
one which is number thirteen et de torre
i don't really tend to wear these sorts
of products much on camera but i wear
them all the time in real life
i find that these are sometimes a bit
shiny and so they don't look as good on
camera
and having more pigmented products
actually looks better on camera
so this one is actually a little bit
darker in real life there is also a
lighter one which is the jujube
this one looks a little bit more natural
this is a little bit more dramatic but
yeah more dramatic than it currently
looks the juicy lasting tints are
definitely the ones i like more
they're really hydrating they keep my
lips looking nice
and it's really easy to reapply it feels
like you're just reapplying lip gloss
with the zero velvet tin i find that the
matte look it looks a little bit
five years ago with the matte lipstick
craze but after you
either blot it off or if you put on a
clear lip gloss over it then it looks
really good i'm not that good at makeup
and so i haven't really mastered the
gradient lip look so i'm sure
there are lots of people using this
matte one really
amazingly but on me i can't make a look
anything other than
straight up 2015. so i hope you like
this video i hope my reviews were
helpful
have you tried any of these products let
me know what you think in the comments
don't forget you can use the discount
code if you want to pick up anything
from stelvana
if you like the video click the like and
the subscribe you can also follow me on
instagram and check out my blog for more
beauty science
see you next time to nerd out more